huh why does salt look so worried what
are you talking about he looks exactly
like he always does to you perhaps but I
finally learned how to read his emotions
his lips are slightly pursed and he's
blinking in Eight Second intervals as
opposed to his normal 10. oh my God
oh my God he's having a meltdown no
don't seems excessive no it's a meltdown
mark my words hey there Captain
everything okay no I'm having a meltdown
we have a few more questions for you
doctor doctor
it's funny when people call dentist
Doctor we are doctors we do four years
of medical school it's called dental
school but we learned about the entire
body but if you had cancer you can call
it dentist you know it's actually harder
to get into dental school than medical
school because there are fewer dental
schools because most people want to
become actual doc that's ridiculous it's
not like we're College professors
calling ourselves doctors not the same
thing my friend sure it is when someone
has a heart attack on the plane do they
yell out yo does anybody here have an
art history PhD a PhD is a doctor red
it's literally describing a doctor maybe
let's refocus no the problem here is
that medical practitioners have co-opted
mean anything and nobody even cares
about
apparently that's a trigger for me yeah
apparently
someone had a good time in Paris oh
Kevin and I shared a perfect week
together I feel like I'm floating on a
croissant I wonder why people don't just
break in a song More Often I've been
asking you for months if I could answer
the phone like
give it a whirl girl
it's rhyming he's telling Gina to sing
get it Holt is on a vacation high he
will say yes to anything right now I
would like a police horse and I'd like
Terry to be riding it almost constantly
I like an HR person to remind everyone
about workplace boundaries the Japanese
make toilet seats would squirt a heated
jet of water right up here I'm gonna
stop you right there bud what we need in
here is an armored personnel carrier a
tank two tanks I want a tank too great
so everyone gets a tank just remember we
can't ruin Captain Holt's vacation high
so no one's say anything that'll upset
him oh no what are those morons doing in
there well maybe it's not that bad maybe
they didn't upset him what did you do
what'd you say nothing we just said
welcome back and laughed with him about
all the weight he gained in France
why is everyone just standing around get
back to work
it's a long Tank Tech I gained three
pounds in Paris three pounds
hurry up I'm starving sorry sorry sorry
sorry I just I just to grab my wall
ET gentlemen
fine I was trying something and it
didn't work I bought a bundle of novelty
shirts at a nearby gift shop this one
says what's up beaches set of
for human reasons but you hate humor
well I'm a joke now so
it suits me this place is so romantic
yeah
and so
intimate don't worry I'm not listening
to you I'm just thinking about how this
sea bass is cold but not as cold and
cruel as the hands of Fate that have
thrust my entire life Into Darkness
damn it I just ordered the sea bass
this is so nice there are hot stones on
our butts for no reason not on mine my
butt Stones keep falling off because I'm
so tense about Hope being here and
ruining everything hasn't been that bad
really
oops sorry can't even float right
just push me away everyone else does
it's not great but as long as we stay in
here we're safe
we're all to Santiago I'm in your room
what how patio door was open I pushed
through the Hedge tell me what is it
about me that screams Loser yeah you
know we're kind of in the middle of
getting massages right now sir oh how
thoughtless of me I'll get down here so
you can see my face oh
hello the question was what is it about
me that screams
for everyone so I guess you believe it
now yeah want to see the Selfies I took
actually yes I'll show the album with
you oh my God I just heard about lunch
she was so young for a redwood tree I
don't understand what's going on why are
you crying a person is dead I feel sad
that's insane you don't feel sad when a
monster dies in a monster movie in E.T
do you feel sad when E.T dies yes he
wasn't a monster he calls a real
commotion it isn't just one I started
seeing a fertility doctor and she has me
taking hormones to help with ovulation
and my emotions aren't overdrive well I
know just the thing to cheer you up
lunch is dead bagel bagel bagel cheddar
has been kidnapped someone took our
Fluffy Boy oh my God what happened well
cheddar and I walked to the bakery
together we shared a planes go and then
we went to the park and I let him off
leash he
came back someone took our Fluffy Boy
right you mentioned that now just to be
clear you didn't actually see someone
take him right so there's a chance
cheddar just ran away you know like some
dogs do whatever isn't some dog he would
never do that someone took our Fluffy
Boy yes I understand I need you to drop
everything nothing in the world is as
important to me as this dog I wouldn't
say nothing for example you and I are
very close we don't have time for this
okay I think it happens The First 48
Hours of the most crucial right and at
dog years that's only seven hours why
would you say that this is why everyone
prefers that dog to you everyone okay
sir the kidnapper should be calling with
his demands any minute if we can trace
his location we can find your fuzzy boy
that fuzzy He's fluffy we don't know
what he is anymore he could be fuzzy it
could be anything Raymond he could be
scruffy now you've upset Kevin I hope
you're happy why would I be happy I
clearly just mixed up fuzzy and fluffy
just you're fired I want your shield and
your peace you took the wrong Fluffy Boy
[Applause]
I will not rest till Justice is served
there's no time to waste this case is
urgent
all right listen the SE may not be quite
as urgent as once thought
um
I dug it up out of my desk so you'd have
something to do on weekends because you
seem so lonely you cited chatter from
the streets that Garibaldi had
resurfaced I did I did I did but said
chatter may have been fudged
so you lied to me
at a pity you pity me I wouldn't put it
that way I would I am offended I am
angry I am very tired so I'm gonna take
a nap but when I wake up oh
you are in for it
[Music]
how dare you how dare me how dare you I
was just trying to help wow your help
feels an awful lot like pity so do me a
favor and don't ever help me again wow
well you didn't seem to mind me helping
you when I got you your job back at the
99 I didn't ask you to do that oh you
said we were out of peas you pee off
you're the PO no you you do
[Music]
is uh everything okay Santiago no I lost
my ring did you see where it went
actually
actually three doors why don't you pick
one are you trying to Monty hole me it's
unbelievable I don't need Monty Hall
ruining my place of work with Monty Hall
has already ruined my home life come on
Sir the math thing isn't the problem
night shift's keeping you and Kevin
apart you two just need a bone
what did you say
I said you two need a bone
how dare you detective Diaz I am your
Superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective is none of your
business
don't ever speak to me like that again
all right